هل يشعر الرئيس بأن
معظم الانتقادات لا تتعلق بمغادرة
أفغانستان ، فهذه هي الطريقة التي
أمر بها بحدوث
ذلك بسحب القوات قبل إخراج
هؤلاء الأمريكيين الذين تقطعت بهم السبل الآن ،
هل يشعر بذلك أولاً وقبل
كل شيء على ما أعتقد  من غير المسؤول أن نقول إن
الأمريكيين تقطعت بهم السبل فهم
ليسوا ملتزمين بإحضار الأمريكيين الذين
يريدون العودة إلى الوطن ، فنحن على اتصال
معهم عبر الهاتف عبر الرسائل النصية عبر البريد الإلكتروني
بأي طريقة يمكننا من خلالها
الوصول إلى الأمريكيين لإعادتهم إلى الوطن إذا أرادوا
للعودة إلى الوطن ، لا يوجد
أمريكيون عالقون ، هو الموقف الرسمي للبيت الأبيض
بشأن ما يحدث في
أفغانستان ، أنا فقط أتصل بك
لقولك إننا نقطع السبل بالأمريكيين
في أفغانستان عندما حددت عندما
كنا واضحين جدًا أننا لن نترك
الأمريكيين  الذين يريدون العودة إلى الوطن
سوف نعيدهم إلى البيت الأبيض
، ومجلس الأمن القومي ،
ووزارة الخارجية ، والبنتاغون ، وكل القوات الموجودة
هناك تعمل.  ليلا ونهارا
لإخراج الأمريكيين ، ولا ينبغي لنا أن
نتظاهر بأنهم ليسوا كذلك ، لكن هذا قال
أيضًا إنه لا شك أيضًا في وجود الأمريكيين في
أفغانستان الذين أعرفهم لحقيقة يشعرون
كما لو أنهم تقطعت بهم السبل على
الأقل حتى الآن